each Linnea geese won't get closer than
a few hundred meters to her former
workplace a massive state hospital on
the outskirts of Istanbul she was a
social worker there earlier this year
she was moved from here against her will
after she went public with one of
turkey's worst social scandals to date
the year before hundreds of underage
girls had given birth here in just five
months around 300 underage girls passed
through the maternity ward a hundred and
fifteen of them were not reported to the
authorities as required by law for two
months I kept going to the clinic
directors and reminding them that these
pregnancies had to be reported but every
time they threw me out of the office and
bullied me more being gay this is a list
of the 115 unreported girls who
delivered in this hospital alone many
were under 15 years of age the Istanbul
public prosecutor launched
investigations into the reported cases
normally in Turkey underage pregnancies
must be investigated by the public
prosecutor but women's organizations
claim that quite often they are not even
in cases with evidence of rape or
illegal underage marriages such crimes
are often committed in schools and
religious boarding schools Deutsche
Welle requested an interview with a
government representative but received
no answer under pressure from the public
the government announced tougher
sentences for pedophiles and rapists on
television deputy prime minister r hf
octa even proposed castrating the
perpetrators but in practice this woman
maintains the authorities often look the
other way her own daughter was secretly
abused by a relative from a very young
age
we got no help of any kind from the
authorities neither legal advice nor
psychological counseling for our
traumatized daughter
we were left completely on our own and
now I ask the politicians why does
someone who's raped a child under 12
years of age get up to 40 years in
prison but someone who's raped a 13 year
old gets at most five years many Turks
doubt their government is serious about
combatting child abuse when the state
religious authority wrote that even
nine-year-old girls were eligible to be
married protests came pouring in the
article containing the statement quickly
vanished each law negates knows all too
well that many people in Turkey still
have that kind of mindset she travels
around the country educating and warning
she doesn't regret going public about
the teen pregnancies after I published
my information the Health Minister
called upon the hospitals to pay more
attention to pregnancies and girls under
18 only proves that a problem does exist
that they can't ignore any longer so why
should I regret anything don't look away
when children are abused or forced into
marriage that's the message naiads has
for listeners all across Turkey for
these aspiring nurses and social workers
for example she explains the laws and
gives advice on how to help those in
need some people blame the many teen
pregnancies on the more than
three-and-a-half million Syrian refugees
in Turkey on maternity ward I mostly had
to do with underage Syrians I was hoping
for some help on how to deal with it
whether Syrians or Turks each sauna
heats cease the struggle against child
abuse in Turkey as the responsibility of
society as a whole
even if only one in a hundred ends up
saying she's going to fight it that
would be fabulous but many more in the
audience may very well be inspired to
take action against child abuse
even if they'll be risking their jobs as
did each loan agates